foreign
[Music]
the death of a star athlete has shocked
the world of track and field three-time
Olympic medalist Tori Bowie was just 32
years old when she died at home last
month an autopsy later revealed she was
eight months pregnant and died of
complications from childbirth the baby
was lost as well this is so tough as
Elise Preston reports the tragedy is
drawing attention to a national crisis
involving black maternal Health Tori
Bowie's prowess and speed led her to the
Olympic gold in 2016's 100 meter relay
agent Kimberly Holland remembers the 32
year old as a Charming Southerner Who
Loved To Laugh she was like a daughter
to me in the spring Holland talked to
Bowie on the phone their last
conversation they were preparing for the
birth of Bowie's baby girl but shortly
after Orange County Florida sheriff's
deputies discovered Bowie dead in her
home during a well-being check after she
had not been seen or heard from in days
a according to an autopsy from the
medical examiner's office Bowie was Home
Alone undergoing labor at the time of
her death no foul play was suspected the
report cited possible complications
including respiratory distress and
eclampsia a rare high blood pressure
condition which could cause seizures
Holland says Bowie was not actively
performing a home birth when her baby
started to arrive I can only imagine now
how that must have been
painful
it hurts also to know that
there's no baby now it's a pain many
black families know well in the U.S
black women are three times more likely
than white women to die from a
pregnancy-related cause is that why she
didn't want to deliver in the hospital
she didn't trust
the hospitals she wanted to make sure
that the baby was going to be okay with
her being in control this is an Olympic
champion and she died as a result of
childbirth what does that tell you it
tells us that there are systemic
barriers that we Face regard to racism
sexism and income inequality and that
shows up in our Health Care system for
CBS mornings Elise Preston Los Angeles